Let's just take a look again if there's activities.
If you remember what we're trying to do is get, keep and grow customers,
and so these things on the left with all these arrows going into the funnel,
those represent all the demand creation activities you were doing either paid or free.
And in the physical channel that we're getting you into the funnel on the top.
And for web, mobile or cloud, we were getting you into the funnel on the bottom.
Now remember, these are just visual representations of the process.
The world doesn't actually look like this but when you get good enough ad,
thus you tend to actually look at your process.
What we are really looking is a funnel laying on its side and you tend to think about
how do we efficiently get payers or users into the funnel and all the way through it.